the night was over for sure in the movie
known as all he was all nervous kz2
Jones talkin a complete string is
resolved
parties digitally uncle the debate a
mullah tsipras's or he was drugged and
he prayed made us pray was awesome
let signature such shit
got it again so
that's like the fucking zoo
so me
tourism
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember so you don't have to director
Martin Campbell has been getting a bit
of a reputation as a savior of
franchises not only de revived the James
Bond movies from total destruction twice
but he also brought the classic Zorro
back from the grave in the mask of Zoro
in the time when everything was CG
explosions and disaster films this gave
us actual stunts developed characters
comedy drama old comers newcomers it was
a reminder of how summer movies were
supposed to be done and of course it was
a big hit so big that everyone involved
went on to do other things the spotlight
was suddenly on these people and they
didn't want this to be the only thing
they were associated but then after a
few shitty movies they said yes yes we
do obvious osya with this remember when
we were good here remember when you
loved us here well we're gonna help you
relive those moments all over again with
us sequel a mere seven years later way
to ride that hot streak guy
but hey even if something came out six
years too late it doesn't mean it
necessarily makes it a bad product no
the fact that it's a bad product is what
makes it a bad product for the first
film had a bit of an edge to it with
family members being killed off and
disembodied heads and jars this one
plays like a fucking Saturday morning
cartoon no drama no logic and stunts
you'd see at a six flag stunt show than
a high-budget sequel it was a pretty
major letdown but it's one thing to talk
about it it's something else entirely to
experience it so let's take a look at
Hollywood should yes sequel so
California is on the verge of becoming
the 31st state as an election is held to
hopefully merge with the Union insert
immediate stupid has oral himself
apparently votes in the election that
must have been an interesting
registration form to fill out okay sir
if you could please fill out your head
no sir that's a ha ha I'm going to meet
your fool ha ha
sir this won't count king whatever ha ha
but a villain with two frozen strips of
bacon on his face comes to steal the
ballots by shooting their hats off take
your business my Gibbons I haven't voted
yet oh I'm sorry you're too late the
polls have already closed don't mess
with me boy I've caused the top-hat
massacre of 43
of course Zorro played by Antonio
Banderas comes in to save the day sir
what do we do he has no head to shoot
and god help us all
he literally tried to steal the election
by putting the votes in a carriage with
the world's fucking strongest horses
that solid brick what kind of steroid
oats are you feeding these things
Oh whoo oh yeah we did the 90s crotch
reaction and it's 2005 oh and yellow -
this denial of reality he lands on a
cactus literally so we can just have
this painfully awkward reaction shot
Jesus even Wiley coyote who said God
knows how many reactions to cactus is
like yeah that was weird - men end up
scenes hora without his mask but right
now that's not an issue as Zorro has
saved the votes yay a dark masked man
whose identity is unknown as handing us
our ballads surely this is diligent
right in three months every vote of
every webinar on California will be
counted and it is my hope that we will
finally call ourselves America I don't
know this film seems way too
Americanized already this of course
brings him back to his lovely wife Elena
played by Catherine zeta-jones
oh by the way get used to this tracking
shot while the music's wounds they milk
him more than the two fat ladies butter
factory
Oh
I don't care if you mug more than the LA
crime circuit one day you will be mine
though it seems he's returned home to
both her and his son he suddenly
realizes that Zoro's days may still not
be over
oh here's me he is quitting let's this
far apart ah you know I'm Catherine
zeta-jones right where's that proof that
you do not know your own son but they
summoned Zorro by ringing the bell five
times because I'm sure was cheaper than
this and he rides off to save the day
again the following morning Jones starts
to feel like she's being watched
oh yeah cuz they look intimidating but
run woman they might start to sing the
banker song from Mary Poppins
yes I probably should have opened with
that can I interest you in a show about
an island that was ruined by a writer's
strike
we then see vendera's at wait a minute
wasn't the last time we saw him he was
being summoned as Zorro
yeah they ring the bells he gets in the
costume he writes off what the fuck
happened in between here quickly Zorro
three naked men in a bathtub are in need
of a dealer go beg Elena's forgiveness
but just when he realizes he should
spend more time with his family and is
about to change his ways his wife issues
a mazy voice oh really
in 1850 huh hell you couldn't even get
away with this in 1950 I think just
thinking the word back then was probably
illegal surrender then oh I don't know
just talk to her and maybe he was wrong
he does the more logical route by
getting blind stinking drunk and bad
talking her for about three months what
happened to my clothes I removed them
last night so you wouldn't catch
pneumonia after you came back from the
cantina you went for a swim the hotel
does have a pool we have a fountain
don't feel sober up soon
this doesn't set well with his son
Joaquin who is trying to get wrestlers
in his studies now exactly there's a
flaming poker fit into your little
theory it fits then mommy oh no okay but
before we proceed any further I just
wanna give you fair warning this is the
stupidest thing you'll see in an action
film for a long time it's actually I'm
amazing if you're wearing glasses or any
kind of eyewear at all be ready to drop
them because this will result in an
immediate baseball
go ahead what the hell am i watching
right now this can't be for real this
cannot be for fucking real how can the
prior film that brought us decapitation
slicing up all their years of torture
bring us the second greater fanfiction
bullshit it is so mind bogglingly stupid
I actually refused to believe it really
happened in my opinion this is all just
a fantasy going on in the kid's head
while in reality he's getting its ass
trashed and this is his only way coping
with it I'm jumping out of the class but
his father sees what he did resulting in
what else absolutely nothing yeah no
punishment no talking
he doesn't even send him back to his
fucking class he simply is what's with
him what's with you huh Christ no wonder
your wife left you your parenting skills
are on par with Octomom but big
surprises dumb behavior doesn't stop
there he's invited to a party hosted by
Rufus I'll pretty much be the bad guy
and everything I'm in so well where he
discovers of Courts that Jones is
getting married to him after being
separated for only three months Hana
Hana Elina Armand la Vega count donkey
thus our brave and virtue is Oro gets
plastered and makes a complete dick of
himself
perhaps you should wear lipstick are you
gonna act like my mother I can handle
her pour to your knees and beg me to
take you back
so drunk he can't even war
to me
Oh his ex-wife he likes to stalk after
getting thrown out of the party he finds
a corner to go get drunk in where
believe it or not even his horse starts
to drink with him nobody lives my
tequila warm dumpling in doing this is
gone stop filming this piece of shit and
start making a real movie I mean a
drunken horse WTF now of course somehow
nobody else heard or saw that giant
explosion which means Banderas is the
only one who can figure out what's going
on an explosion I simply wanted to make
sure you were both safe well as much as
you ought to drink last night I'm sure
your vision was impaired yes but my
hearing isn't what the hell kind of
accent are you trying to do
you don't play polo etiquette that's
right remember when this music used to
go to cool stuff in the first film it
was a horse chase a sword fight now it's
goddamned polo Oh
they just keep upping the fucking ante
don't they
Oh to the victor go the spoils so after
that completely pointless exchange
temporary tattoos here goes to steal the
deed to a person's house so he can own
their land listen yo this lend so we
have an Lord shall expel them before you
he shall possess their land you know I
don't think he knows what those words
actually mean I think he just memorized
random passages thinking they'll sound
important man Samson visited his wife
with a young goat and said I will go
into my wife in her room wow that
sounded bad okay just forget that last
verse that's a than that lads not me
drop your guns I love you
Zorro has them where he wants them tells
the couple to go inside
yeah then just takes off like a pussy
wait he tells them to go inside the
house and then doesn't even stay to
protect them that's like telling your
mouth go get the cheese from the
mousetrap I shall be with you in spirit
from afar this leads to the husband
getting killed but luckily Zoro's force
is inflammable and saves the wife and
kid our horse is just like super beans
in this world eventually Zorro sneaks
into the bad guys house while Jones does
pretty much the exact same thing where
is the bathroom I would like a powder on
my cheeks yes your tan does seem to be
coming off Feliz Navidad assholes
I am Zorro they'll take my boys two days
to cover the quarter-mile
otherwise you're getting nothing listen
to me backwards ass frog you had John my
money you won't ever see me Christ I am
so bad at what I do
do you have a Bible quote you especially
afraid of our two heroes bump into each
other after snooping around leading to
Zorro having to hide hmm Jesus I think
man about you and less bickering than
this film
we're hoping to get the horses own
nickelodeon show check your local
listing so in the mother of all
coincidences barbecue sauce tear happens
to stop by a field trip that Sorrell son
happens to be a part of and happens to
sneak a Ford without being seen kill
coincident kid looking at two of the
ugliest guys I've ever seen
no so all we can do is duck from its
aroma pleasing destruction Zoro st.
Simon gets into safety only to be
captured himself by the people who know
his identity where the Pinkertons
operatives of the United States
government Elena
works for you so as you probably figured
out these are agents who blackmailed
Jones to be a spy for them so they can
stop whatever evil plans are well is up
to okay two major problems with this one
why the fuck couldn't she tell him that
even if they threatened to kill him or
her she can still tell him if he can
just be on his guard second and
definitely the bigger problem here you
find out who's Oro is and you decide to
use his wife why the fuck don't you use
arrow
I mean he's ro he's fuckin sorrow he's
literally an action hero yeah go for his
wife the fuck's wrong with you how would
this make sense in any reality I know
who you are
Bruce and if you don't want me to tell
the cops out there
I think you know what I want you to give
me and what is that
I want Alfred my Butler yeah why the
hell do you want my Butler Oh
Commissioner Gordon all right all right
I'll give him the ball Alfred
boy get down there boy it's on his way
now you do know I'm Batman right yeah I
don't care
I can bug fun sneak into places I still
want my healthy okay I don't paw this at
all
all right there I'm swipe kites darling
I can do gasoline drawings on a bridge
we don't care I am so done with this
cake
you
so as if the Zorro couldn't possibly be
any more pathetic in this film he ends
up getting stuck in jail and has to rely
on his son to break him out
that's right an 8-year old little boy is
going to break out Xaro his son of
course has a foolproof way to break him
out he just bent over Christ's evil my
dumb guard standards as borderline
brain-dead what he couldn't dress up
like a woman and lure him with his
feminine wiles
he then meets up with Jones at our
villains headquarters Saturday says
pretty late that was pretty lame they
then discover that so well as part of
the Knights of evil smoky rooms who want
to stop California from becoming a state
as well as destroy all of America power
of the United States will be so great
it will overshadow us but
America has one weakness just one it's
people not sure and all of this
nitroglycerin here preparing to launch a
preemptive strike against Washington
I've had enough
brothers you know my spirit is with you
but we risk antagonizing a sleeping
giant do we fail I'll see myself out as
a member of an evil organization I
expect no retaliations resulting in the
end of me whatsoever are dealing god oh
yeah with a demonstration put your mind
at ease actually I think it would thank
you very much my god I could hear that
cliche all the way over here unless you
come to confess you have no business
here we didn't so interview with a
redneck vampire here's that Zorro
visited the priest and dropped off the
boy there and like most religious nuts
he shouts his damn bible quotes
everywhere except in the goddamn church
all right
I'll tell you wow I really do think this
is the most useless villain I have ever
seen on film and he hasn't done one
thing luckily I think the killer from
screen Ellis pratfalls than this guy
I'm so sorry Padre if you had a hat I
would have shot that they take the kid
away as Zorro the master of disguise
sneaks into where they're making the
night row without ever being know did
everybody just come down with the case
of the stupids seriously how many people
are working in this damn place not one
of them fucking one of them notices that
one of them is wearing a black mask is
so obviously Zorro all of him is exposed
except for his hat
oh haha we got you now zorb santa claus
our apologies we thought your Zorro oh
it's no problem but the for your
disobedience go cut your head off but
only the Emperor can demand such your
majesty now get to the choppa choppy ha
they're all eventually caught and his
son is shown whose aura was the whole
time Bobby and as you can see his
amazement fades quite quickly yeah would
have been cooler for you a Spider Man
goodbye de la Vega no please this is the
one time I can actually do something
right I don't know my family is my life
and seeing how my life is about to be
dead you can kind of see where you lie
on the totem pole okay
so this guy has Xaro he's got a knife to
his fucking neck there's no way he can
escape what does he do pushes him away
giving him time to fight back this guy
he's unbelievable the only thing he got
done in this movie was shoot the fucking
priest and even then I think that was
just a lucky shower
oh my god are you fucking kidding me
he didn't even kill the goddamn priest
Clemmy bribed man claiming prize you are
the most worthless villain in film
history oh but it doesn't stop there I
know that sounds unbelievable but he
actually does manage to get stupider
this idiot he's so goddamn dumb but that
sorrel doesn't have to end up killing
him he actually ends up killing himself
I'm not even kidding he goes out like a
whiny pussy bitch
even his scream was embarrassing give it
up for amazing Jenner he will never see
a less intimidating antagonist well done
sir well done oh and how did the priests
survive that gunshot you might ask yes
no really guess because there's only one
thing to guess and it's of course the
right answer you know you're thinking it
go ahead you can say it out loud for
crosslet God works in mysterious cliches
fuck Kirk Cameron is more subtle than
you so it goes after a train filled with
nitro which also holds his family and
coincidentally picks the exact light
window to punch to be fair though I do
love this line so the death Allah knows
thank you I can handle my own paperwork
they strap John Murdoch to the front of
the train where he blows up with the
Nitro and thank God somebody started to
build a brick wall but then stars one
idiot of the way through welcome to the
union governor yeah we belong to a
country that's still using slavery
freedom wonderful freedom our heroes
decide to get remarried only to find the
bells are summoning Zorro again and I
guess everybody's okay with him
abandoning his family now
Wagner honey how are you double itto the
people look homie let's hear it for our
hero who has gone through absolutely no
change whatsoever Debbie
anything
aged Jesus Christ what the hell happened
the first film was so good and it's so
hard to believe that the same people
were involved with it the characters are
idiots who don't learn anything the
fighting is way too silly to get
invested in the humor is not funny the
drama is not interesting it just feels
like it was written by a child I still
stand by the phrase or movie with Ben
Darras and Xena Jones is an action
Marvel one of the most entertaining of
the past few decades but this this is
just a disaster it killed the chance of
there ever being a Zorro movie in the
near future but hey if it was with these
people again maybe that was a good thing
cuz I don't think I could sit through a
piece of crap like this ever again well
maybe they change one thing that could
work now Matt's still stupid I'm not a
scholar critic I remember so you don't
have to
listen to me backwards ass frog